build it draw it
client Vsauce is your home some of the
coolest creations from everyday people
this is beanie people building artist
Chungcheong homemade this world record
longest continuous wooden sculpture it's
a replica of the famous painting along
the river during the qin Ming festival
and it took four years to create and as
about 12 meters long 3 meters high and
2.4 meters why Henry Hargreaves and
Caitlin Levin created these gingerbread
replicas of well-known art museums from
around the world including the Tate
Modern in London the Louvre in Paris and
the Guggenheim in New York all of the
candy was from Dylan's Candy Bar where
they were asked to create something
unique for an art show yo'ii kasama
created these infinity rooms for a show
called I who have arrived in heaven
they're mirrored environments that trick
the eye and create an unusual viewing
experience and they're so popular that
the wait to view the rooms can be
anywhere from 1 to 4 hours the artist
now in her mid 80s is also showing off
27 large-scale paintings draw shanti
krumbine creates intricate art using the
New York Times the work is called
kenosis which is a Greek noun for
emptiness or emptying and she takes
headlines such as Tropical Storm Irene
in the midst of losses and bin Laden's
secret life and turns them into
something new by removing parts of the
image and story
Dena Tomac of atomic circus sent me
these amazing hyper-realistic
large-scale mixed-media drawings of his
family that include his father mother
grandfathers and grandmothers each one
took over 70 hours to create and he used
water-based colored pencils dry pastel
and tattoo color and now for some
incredible drawings from the YouTube
channel of marchello Barranca
Taal Peleg is a makeup artist whose
canvas is the human eye her work
includes a wide range of themes such as
this steampunk style Rudolph the Red
Nosed Reindeer sushi The Ugly Duckling
Pink Floyd's the wall and a cat playing
with yarn lion
Tyler Freeman created drum pants a
wearable sensor that turns your clothes
into a drum kit chicago's magical piano
was set up by Amtrak and rob bliss
creative to respond to commuters passing
by
here's Julien playing the drums for Wiki
drummer calm and a range of settings
showcasing how different locations
affect the sound finally here's the
official video for security by Sega
bodega created by a doshu
submit your bidipis as a personal
message here on youtube or share them
with everyone over at
facebook.com/vsaucetwo wo
click here listen to a brand new
installment of bdp radio music created
and submitted by you guys also check out
your bidipi entire video dedicated to
only your creations and as always thanks
for watching